if you were to sit down with trump what
would you be asking him right now
i'd ask him what he thought about what
happened on
in in the capitol in the day of the
riots
what's his story about that he's
addressed that what did he think
that yeah but i'd like to i'd like to go
go after it in depth um
i'd i'd like to ask him about um
who he thinks think he thought he
appealed to and why and
and what he did that he thought worked
um i'd like to ask him what he thinks
about the
the accusations of that pertain to his
reprehensibility his character
and and what he thinks about that and
how how he would respond to that
but i'd like to find out like i wouldn't
be interested in hurling accusations or
or i'd like to find out what he thinks
because
god wouldn't he like to know what trump
thinks
i'd love to know what he thinks we need
to know because
half the population voted for him why do
you think
why do you think opposition doesn't want
you to know what he's thinking
what do you think they're scared of i
think they're scared of all sorts of
things i think they
they're they're they're scared of the
possibility that
he has uh the power of a demagogue
that he's a a populist that that he
could harness the crowd for nefarious
ends uh
they're concerned about his respect for
democratic norms and and the standard um
what would you say his respect for the
authorities of the state
you know they view him as a as a muslini
in the making
let's say and so that's their fear
and you know there are mussolini's in
the making and trump was a populist and
so
that's where that fear comes from um
there's also fear
of course because some people think one
way politically and a lot of this is
temperamentally based and
other people think another way and it's
hard for them to communicate across the
divide
um so that's some of the fear but you
know
it has to be addressed because you you
in the u.s there's this problem that
fifty percent of
this problem this situation fifty
percent of the people voted for trump
that can't just be swept under the rug
if you can't sweep something like that
under the rug
like at all and so what
what's going to be the consequence of of
stopping him from speaking
why would you think that all the
consequences of that are going to be
good
i don't think they're going to be good i
mean certainly a large part of the
american population
felt like they were punched
by the large media companies the large
social media companies
you know because they were affiliated
with trump and all of a sudden he was
silenced so all those people feel that
they've been silenced
well they have been well you might say
well those are precisely the people who
should be silenced just really is that
what you think
you think 25 of your population should
be silenced
do you what does that say about you
and what are you going to do with those
25 you have to live with them
christ you're probably related to a
bunch of them
so it's not a good solution
i don't think does it backfire on them
it always backfires i mean if you assume
that
how could it not backfire if if if
investigating something complex is
worthwhile how could failure to
investigate it not backfire
it's not like the conditions that gave
rise to trump
are likely to magically vanish you know
now it's possible that if biden does a
credible job
or even a great job and i hope he does
that
that political temperature will lower
and and this will become a non-issue
essentially
if we're lucky it'll just fade away and
trump is getting old too you know
there is that blunt fact
and so maybe we'll just move on to other
things and it's possible that that might
be
the outcome we should hope for but
what do you mean well that we get on
with the next thing
you know do you think that's a good
thing because
well i don't know i don't know i really
don't know i mean i wish biden well i
hope he does
a good job because he's your president
and wouldn't it be good if he did a good
job you guys need a good president
um and maybe there are things that we
should be
focusing our attention on right here and
now
yeah i just think i think you know like
the topic of jfk assassination
right so the jfk assassination topic
till today
people want to figure out what really
happened the debate still steers it up
every
november 22nd people oh well this is
what happened no that's what happened oh
this is what happened no it's really
this is what happened no no now we have
the real story
movie after movie after movie after
movie after movie
we don't want to have we don't have any
way to go get a hundred percent definite
you know definitive answer
everything's going to be 82 92 63
we're not going to get 100 right trump
is around right now
there's a lot to learn about what
happened and i'm not even i'm not making
it
like when you're saying let's move on i
don't mean move on like you know well
he's going to die and move on
not talking about that i don't i don't
think things should be brushed under the
rug and i i don't think that usually
works i've never seen it work
yeah i think there's so much market
research right now for us to find out
about what's going to happen
if we don't figure out what really
happened and the amount of power
clarence thomas today came out and he
said he made some comments about section
230. i don't know if you read that or i
don't know if you heard about that
uh what he thinks about section 230 you
know the common carrier rules on twitter
you may want to look it up because he
kind of commented on it today
and it's creating frenzy when dennis
prager and i who's a good friend of mine
i think he's also a good friend of yours
when you're done under a fair bit of
censorship pressure which i'm
happy about yes and you know his wife
sue is a lawyer
when they went up against youtube they
ended up
losing because the court finally said
no they have the right because the same
rules that apply to government doesn't
apply to a private company because if
they don't want to
a you know they want to do whatever you
want they can do it they're not a
government they don't
they don't go based on the same rules of
freedom of speech they can do whatever
they want to do
the government can the government's
gotta allow you to speak right and so
i was speaking to a guy this last week
who bought uh medecovin you may not know
medicoven i don't know if you've been
following nfts or not medicalman is the
guy
who's a crypto billionaire who bought
people's every days for 69.3 million
dollars and we're talking about
where do you live right now since i live
in uh i live in uh
uh uh singapore so why do you live in
singapore you're indian why why
singapore why not us he says well i
lived in canada
i lived in a few different places uk but
i chose singapore i said why not us he
smiles and he's not a
energetic speaker like the way he's not
like that he's very
you know calm the way he speaks he says
i didn't want to go to us
because u.s it's all they have
fingerprints on you and it's like a web
they're going to figure out a way to get
the taxes on he says listen i live in
singapore
zero in capital gains taxes i said zero
is a zero you don't pay any capital so
why would you pay capital gains taxes
you know our ordinary income is 10 or 20
no regulation
i don't have to you know tell the
government what i have and hey here's
how much money i have i don't want to
tell anybody what i have so i can keep
it to myself it's my business if i go to
u.s
i have to tell everybody what i have et
cetera et cetera
and sitting i'm like huh singapore okay
interesting you know trump here
he's going through what he's going
through this guy's over here living free
and then he says you have to realize
that nowadays twitter facebook youtube
these things are virtual governments
and they are controlling america america
is no longer what america used to be
america is a whole different america so
for us if we don't get to the bottom of
this today
i think a lot of people who have a voice
are going to be bullied for decades
and i think we got to get to the bottom
of a while you know we have the ability
to sit down and trump's got to be
interviewed properly where someone's
going to learn the other day his
daughter-in-law interviewed him
facebook took the interview down i don't
know if you saw that when the you know
laura does the interview
so it would be very interesting to see
someone like yourself interview him
yeah well i'd i would love to do that i
think it would be well how could it fail
to be anything but fascinating at least
for me
hopefully for people who are viewing it
you know
it's a complicated it's a complicated
problem but
my sense is that you tell people what's
going on
and let them figure it out you can't
hide it anyways if it's real you can't
hide it it comes out
you can't hide reality it always comes
out
and usually if you try to hide it it
comes out in a much worse form
that that's my experience as a
psychologist i've never seen anyone
successfully hide anything in their life
not really it leaks out in all sorts of
ways
they don't necessarily even make the
connection but but
they can discover the connection later
and be very sad about it so if you like
this sort of shortcut from an interview
i did click over here to watch the
entire
interview and please don't forget to
subscribe to the channel take care
everybody bye
[Music]
you